then they go on to make their point
about the cabinet and this
is what is so preposterous
they believe that the cabinet this lame
drawling drooling old desiccated cabinet
are superheroes what we saw today i was
sitting in that room in wilmington um i
was thinking about the fact that joe
biden in some ways
first supporters is fulfilling the
promises that he made on the campaign
charlie said he wanted to have a cabinet
that looked like america and there were
people there on that stage of course
talking about all of their different
accolades and their experience but they
were also talking about their families
who survived the holocaust who survived
coming from cuba and flink
communists who talked about um having
gumbo
diplomacy cooking food cooking southern
food
as the united nations ambassador things
um all of those things are what america
is about it's a melting pot the other
thing i'll just say is i was talking to
a democrat
who just said this also felt like the
avengers it felt like we're being
rescued from this
this craziness that we've all lived
through from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all
here are the superheroes and what are
their qualifications what are their
superpowers
can they fly no can they think
not really but they can look a certain
way
yes they can have different colors of
skin
and this is an amazing superpower
different sexual appendages
i know that you know all those things
were true under trump too but
you know it's super duper under joe
biden
uh this is identity politics on steroids
right this is what this woman says
we need a cabinet that looks like
america well what do you mean by looks
like america you mean
do you mean in the sense that the
cabinet thinks like americans think
that the cabinet has the same love of
country that
americans generally have that they have
the same interests the same hobbies the
same cares and concerns
no what she means is they've got to be
diverse
meaning you know different colors and
sex and everything and when they say
look like america by the way what
they're really saying is actually look
more diverse than america you have to
have one of
every single type of person with certain
physical traits
there's something beyond stupid here
obviously it's very stupid and shallow
and pretty offensive but there's
something beyond that that's that's even
it's even more depressing which is that
the focus on identity politics here the
color and sex of these cabinet picks
shows you that the individual members
don't matter at all
it doesn't matter if any of these people
are talented
and from the pics that we've heard of so
far they're not talented
they're not particularly intelligent
they're not particularly accomplished
none of these guys most especially john
kerry
they're just there to fill a space to be
an empty suit because they are the
conduit for the liberal technocracy
to rule that's the i mean that's the the
really revealing aspect of the identity
politics is no one is focusing on
whether these people are competent to do
their jobs and
they're not actually but it doesn't
matter because they're not even doing
the jobs
we have had in this country for decades
now
a bureaucracy that operates largely
without democratic oversight
that just makes all our policy for us
the presidents may change but the
foreign policy is supposed to
stay the same the administrations may
come and go
but the giant bureaucracy that employs
millions of people will keep
will keep operating and trump disrupted
that in a limited way
he wasn't able to totally upend the deep
state or the bureaucracy but he made
changes here and there changed policy a
little bit and then the
establishment fought back they think
that they vanquished him we still don't
know for sure
and now they want to govern again
without any of that democratic oversight
and so all of these
these uh cabinet picks and
joe biden himself they will be little
ornaments on the christmas tree little
shiny things to look at
but the substance of the government will
be that
bureaucracy i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts